now detectives have resumed their search
for a body after four people were
arrested over slavery allegations in
South Wales Fraser Maud is at the scene
in Peterson in Newport and dirt tell us
what's happening there then Fraser this
is all part of what went police are
calling operation Imperial it's been six
months in the planning ever since 43
year old man was found in this area
living in very poor conditions they said
that man had actually been reported
missing from his home in Worcestershire
some 13 years earlier now a hundred
officers took part in these in carrying
out these warrants four people were
arrested two of them here at this farm
property in between newport and cardiff
as another man was arrested in cardiff
and a 42 year old woman was arrested in
the pen how area of wales it's been six
months in the playing as I say the 100
officers carried out these arrests in it
and as part of the investigation here at
this farm there now carrying out
searches excavations because they've
been given suggestions that there may
well be a body buried somewhere on this
property now those searches are expected
to take something like three days police
say the state's initially based on
information that there may be a body
they say that is only a suggestion but
clearly they're taking that suggestion
seriously enough to to bring in an awful
lot of manpower to try and carry out
this search they've got a forensic
archaeologist they've got scene of crime
officers they've got excavation units
they're using ground x-ray equipment as
well to try and identify if there is a
body buried anywhere in the farmland
around the the property here which was
the center of the the warrant execution
yesterday now the police say that this
is all part of an investigation into
allegations relating to slavery and
servitude they also recovered an Eastern
European man from this property they say
they can't confirm his age as yet they
say that they can't either confirm the
the conditions in which he was living in
they say has been taken to a place of
safety and they'll continue to question
him to find out exactly why he was here
in the conditions he was living in they
say that it's a joint approach this a
multi-agency approach from gwent police
they say they're also including the Red
Cross and the Serious Organised Crime
Agency as well they
call for me at how far-reaching this
investigation is going to be they say
they want to carry out the immediate
searches say they want to continue
questioning the four people who've been
arrested and the man the Eastern
European man who has recovered from this
site in order to determine how far their
investigations are going to go they've
been granted an extra 12 hours already
to continue questioning those four
people that extension will run out
sometime overnight so they'll have to
apply for more time from a magistrate if
they want to continue questioning the
four people that were arrested yesterday
but in the meantime dozens of officers
here at the scene continuing the search
for what they think may well be a body
in the area